all right so again thank you for
everybody for coming and also for people
who are returning back thanks for for
sure enough so again we'd like to always
acknowledge high data people that are
helping to sponsor so num focus for
sponsoring the meet of itself TD
Ameritrade for the venue
ed / spark for helping with all the
advertising then also Midas who usually
provides food we're working on it so I
promise up there that the pizza is
coming at the end of this I'm still
thankful as always important points for
people who have not been here emergency
exists there's one right here and
there's one right outside the door that
you injured we're always soliciting for
speakers especially local one okay so we
do have a line up of a lot of speakers
that we like to advise but we would love
for people around the communities to
talk and then always provides Ben and I
who tend over here any feedback so
please tweet at us or send us a message
on Meetup let us know how we're doing
things that you would like to see so you
can always like to come give a talk you
can always grab a lot of the speaker's
slides hopefully Jennifer will share the
slides afterwards that we like to post
it up on the idata and our very github
page and just be mindful of time unless
you the question is quick
please hold them until the end we kind
of got a little bit carried away last
time and also remember that we're in
Vorlon space so please do clean up after
yourselves if food shows up and for
newcomers I'd like to instead of remind
us of the Haggadah
code of conduct so PI D day is dedicated
to providing a harassment free meeting
experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
rates of religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communication should be
appropriate for professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meetup
events please be kind to others do not
insult if we're down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist rates districts
visionary jokes are not appropriate for
pi da da
attendees value in these rules if you
have to leave the meet up at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers but
thank you for helping making help making
this a welcoming and friendly event for
everybody okay and as always an
icebreaker
today's icebreaker is so that you get to
meet somebody hopefully before we leave
today X Rika is choose between the
following two options superpowers either
flying or invisibility turn to your
neighbor choose one and explain why you
threw that one introduce yourself don't
forget that go ahead try and then from
the drawing log I really wish your
worship you'll actually get my cue to
see individually and price points dollar
line wall there
[Music]
[Music]
hopefully we'd like to point out our
data science thing of the month this
this month is a blog post or actually go
with the book it's an online book called
from Python numpy so if you typically
you know coded Python and your figure
trying to figure out what are some of
the best ways to do vectorization or to
speed up your python code this blog post
is fantastic this is one of the examples
where they code up how to do this I
guess classic computer science problems
all boys so these are actually birds
digital birds that are flocking together
and flying together and they show
examples of how one would pull that up
in Python and using the sender's list
but also how to do that in numpy but
they got tons and tons of examples again
this will be posted on our github page
so I urge everybody to go check it out I
absolutely love this they've got tons
and tons of content there and we want to
do a quick poll just just so we know
what our audiences how many here are
currently in academia or in school or
what was recently in school okay and
then how many in industry corporate
world working transitioning school about
50/50 alright and don't forget to tweet
out at I didn't Arbor to grab yours free
or i'li ebook and also key Ameritrade
we're hiring so either
software stuff rendered developer or if
your data scientist and also don't
forget that our next event is coming up
on Thursday July 13th and we're having
Gus Gordon from console PS coming
talking about designing an algorithmic
trading strategy in Python and I think
then something good yes so so we have
these events once a month we're looking
to maybe expand to maybe doing some
workshops or something a little bit more
hands-on Marquez's is generous enough to
help kind of leave this thing but we
don't know where we should start first
because we don't know much my view so if
you feel like sharing maybe tweet at us
about the kind of thing that you want to
do that's a little bit more hands-on
like these events are great we get to
learn about what's going on but maybe
there is something that we want to do a
little bit more intro to that that's
interactively how to do stalker hands
Nettie's we be how to do that to those
questions last me nuts or an interview
numpy or maybe advanced Empire though
those kinds of things if there isn't a
large response maybe we want to do it as
often but if there's a there's a large
responsible we'll try to do them maybe
on that every day every two weeks is
we're going to start off with just want
to see how it goes that tells what you
are tells it yeah yeah so without
further ado we have Jennifer Mars man
here today she went to school not too
far from here Rob well yeah
both our undergrad as officer masters
and currently she is a developer
developer evangelist as well as a
principal software development engineer
Wow even look at backing up Microsoft
upon dark matter and so let's give her a
round of buzz
yes it is I'm hello everyone thank you
so much for having me here I really
appreciate and I have a feeling I'm
going to love this crowd just based on
the spirited debate around - the
superpower thing I think we're all on
the same page here so it seems like a
really good group so what I wanted to
talk today about is specifically an
introduction to Azure machine learning
so just so I have a sense of those who
are in the room how many of you people
are so how many people are machine
learning experts or consider themselves
machine learning experts awesome okay
and then how many people have a basic
familiarity with machine learning okay
awesome
and then how many people are primarily
think of themselves as a Python
developer but not necessarily know much
about machine learning okay cool Coco
cool all right so the reason I ask is we
were talking about like Shawn and I were
talking about what talk to do and I
thought that maybe this would be a good
one it's a new tool or something else
that you could have in your toolbox in
terms of when you're writing code and
such and there's a little bit of kind of
some data science in here so I'm hoping
it's not too introductory or maybe two
introductory and you guys maybe beyond
this so we'll see how it goes but this
is one of the just basic intro talks I
do in machine learning so we have more
advanced questions feel free to let me
know those at the end of the talk as
well and I'm happy to jump into those -
all right so what we're going to do is
I'm going to start with just like ten
slides do a little context for those who
don't have the machine learning
background on supervised machine
learning and then the majority of it I'm
just going to spend on demo so we're
going to dive into a demo and talk about
specifically who would survive the
Titanic how many people have heard of
Kegel okay oh yeah this is a yacht you
guys are a great thing so we're going to
go through the the Titanic Kaggle
challenge which sounds like a lot of you
are familiar and by the way been and
should they believe been in Sean my vote
if or if we do hands-on is I think we
should all get together and do a Kaggle
challenge together I think I'd be fun my
vote for the hands-on thing is like
let's all to get together and do a tag
I'll challenge I think that'd be fun
yeah okay so so let's get started and my
contact information is there if you have
any questions that weren't able to be
answered feel free to hit my blog or
Twitter
I'm pretty pretty easy to find online
hopefully all right so let's start with
just kind of the basics of supervised
machine learning so machine learning all
up there's several different categories
of it
reinforcement learning whereas you get
kind of a turn-based thing and you can
get rewards and benefit or rewards based
on kind of moving towards closer to your
goal and such there's unsupervised
learning which you can do things like
clustering and things like that and what
I'm going to focus on today is
supervised machine learning and so what
that is is using a series of historical
data to be able to make future
predictions so for example one might
want to predict the cost of a home all
right and so if you wanted to do that
what you would need is something that we
call a label so here is my my labeled I
have a label data set here of the
various homes and how much they actually
cost and then I also would have what we
call features and features are things
that would affect that label alright so
if I'm trying to predict the cost of a
home the square footage may be very
relevant to how you know how much it
costs on the zip code right because a
house in Silicon Valley of that's 3,000
square feet is going to cost a very
different amount than a house in Detroit
that is on 3,000 square feet there's
also a a number of other things right
number of bedrooms number of bathrooms
size of the master bath for some reason
people really care about having a big
master bath a number of years since the
kitchens then you know renovated those
kind of things so there may be a whole
bunch of different features like that
and we would have in real life we would
have more than just two this is a very
very simplified thing we'd have more
than two features but we have a whole
bunch of features and then some label
that's associated with them so for this
historical data this was the right
answer this was the price and then we
would have a lot more rooms than this
too you'd want a lot of data to
represent a thing you get a good general
sense of a bunch of different scenarios
across your the data sets that you're
trying to get information on so what and
then all the supervised machine learning
is doing is using crazy beautiful maps
find the correlations between these
features and that label and the actual
way it's done is different depending on
the type of machine learning algorithm
that you're using so you guys may have
heard IRA's are also missing in this
room everyone is may be familiar with
these already but the difference between
like neural nets and Bayesian algorithms
and decision trees and you know linear
regressions so there's all they're all
just different kinds of math that help
you find correlations between those and
the math is all a little bit different
so some of them work better in certain
situations than other ones do just based
on kind of what your data set looks like
all right so that's what genome is and
then so finds the correlations we build
a model that represents okay they send
all this data that I've consumed my
training data I build a model and then I
can pass it that model that I've created
I can pass it just the features now now
that I kind of learned from this
historical data I can say all right so
for a given square footage and zip code
and whatever other features we choose
how much should it cost and then based
on what it's learned it can give me a
price back all right so that's kind of
the very basics of supervised machine
learning all right and so in Azure
machine learning specifically there is
support for four different categories of
algorithms there's actually 25
underlying algorithms that are in there
right now and their support for kind of
in those in general terms are for
different categories and so the first
two are classification and regression so
classification and regression are both
examples of supervised machine learning
that I was just talking about the
difference between them is
classification is when you want to
predict between multiple discrete
buckets right is my husband lying or
telling the truth is this particular is
who's going to win the big game Michigan
or Michigan State is is someone going to
get readmitted to the hospital within
the next 90 days yes or no
so those times it doesn't to be binary
either it doesn't have to be just two
options you could say you know this set
of pixels which color does it map to red
yellow green blue you know and have four
different options so there can be
multiple options there so that's
classification discrete buckets right if
you're coming from
developer background think about
basically anything that you would create
like an enumeration for right like I
have these different kind of states and
then I'm assigning them all number and
you can build a classification on them
all right the other one is regression so
regression is is actually this example
right here is a regression problem
regression is when the thing you're
trying to predict is a value on a
continuum or a number so in this case
even though in my training data in this
if I just use this amount of data I
don't have anything that's twenty-five
hundred thousand dollars but the model
could still predict twenty five hundred
thousand dollars because it can
extrapolate or interpolate between those
values right with the up with our
classification it's only going to use
the discrete buckets that you define in
the training set regression is it's
going to predict a number and it can
find new numbers outside of your
training set and that sort of thing all
right
fabulous all right and then so an
example and I think well breast cancer
is does this person have breast cancer
or not maybe another thing predicting
the price of a home regression anomaly
detection is kind of an interesting sub
sample for a very specific problem so
consider the problem of credit card
fraud detection that's actually kind of
a tricky problem because when you look
at a typical credit card transaction
database what it usually looks like is
you have all of these valid transactions
right a lot of valid transactions and
then you have a very very small subset
of them or fraudulent transactions
hopefully it's pretty small fraudulent
transactions and then the known
fraudulent transactions is even smaller
still right so here's my known
fraudulent transactions and here's all
these you know valid transactions and
it's actually really hard to build a
model when you have a highly unbalanced
data set like that when it's like all of
these mapped to you know valid in all of
these these small number of maps to
fraudulent and so techniques like
anomaly detection can actually help
account for that where you kind of say
this is the realm of normal and then
these are have anomaly so we you can use
this for credit card fraud detection you
can use it for network intrusion
detection Microsoft does that for some
reason who knew people actually love to
hack
the xbox live gamer system who wouldn't
think you know who would have thought
but people really really really want to
get more gamer points and so they try
some really funny things to be able to
do that
so um anomaly diction is a good thing
you can use their there's also a private
interesting thing that I did once with
um with a group of folks down in Texas
that we're dealing with the issue of oil
oil and gas pipelines so I don't
actually know what ton about the oil and
gas industry but apparently uh you know
these are very precious natural
resources and you know that and so
sometimes people will actually try to
siphon and these huge pipelines okay and
they run through these places in Texas
and Alaska and such where there's just
no one there for miles and miles of
mouths so black market or whatever
people will sometimes try to siphon off
oil or gas or something from these these
pipelines and I mean best-case scenario
that's stealing and it's wrong and they
shouldn't do that but worst-case
scenario is that these lot of these
materials are very volatile and can
explode fairly easily and so like things
can happen and entire pipelines can
explode and really really bad things can
go wrong and so having it we were
designing anomaly detection for
detecting that something was going wrong
or the pipeline flow is being reduced in
something that was outside of normal and
stuff so there's kind of an interesting
problem as well and then finally
clustering so clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning although these
have been supervised learning so
unsupervised learning you don't actually
have to have a label with your dataset
so you don't need a label data set like
that you can just have a whole bunch of
data and maybe do something interesting
with it a lot of times in recommendation
engines you might want to do some
clustering first so if I wanted to
recommend a restaurant to you or I'm
good movie to see you could cluster you
know like restaurants together like
movies together that sort of thing to be
able to make a recommendation to someone
okay alright so that's kind of a so
every machine learning has support for
these four categories of algorithms and
then there's a whole bunch of algorithms
inside of each of these so all of that
that I've talked to you so far up to
here is just kind of machine learning in
general information so this is a little
bit more specific to Azure ml and so as
your machine
has 25 different machine learning
algorithms inside of it and so basically
it's very very easy to use like
drag-and-drop interface will do that
today I'll just build one from scratch
and you can kind of see how it looks and
habit is another tool in your toolkit if
you like there are modules for importing
data cleaning data and doing all kinds
of things of particular interest to this
group there is an execute Python module
in there so what you can do is actually
drag and drop in a little module and
then be able to run your Python code in
there and there's actually a lot of
companies that I'm working with that are
using Azure machine learning like just
for that like the deployment story is
actually pretty nice because you just
hit a button and it deploys and that
sort of thing so they're actually doing
they're like writing their Python and
then just creating a whole like a
machine learning project that's just one
module of your Python and then using
that to run the whole thing so and if
you guys will see that and then we can
talk about that more at the end if you
like to do that I'm seeing some smiles
so there may even be some people in the
audience that are different right now
but well because are a little bit more
about that and I'll show you some of the
cleaning and all kinds of good stuff
that we can do but you you water up
these things it's a very easy kind of
drag-and-drop where we're up the data
flow you can train your models test your
models and then the deployment really
use is pretty beautiful coming from
someone who hates dealing with
deployment it's literally like a button
press and then you it stands up a rest
endpoint for you and it generates code
and three different languages for you to
actually call the endpoint it creates a
good to use as your API key so that way
it's secured only people with the API
key can access your endpoint so there's
just kind of a nice publication model
too so okay all right so here is one
potential way of doing supervised
machine learning there are others as
well on cross-validation and some other
stuff but we're going to kind of look at
the simple case here so we're going to
start with some data set and we'll see
how to do that and then we can do a
series of we can do various data
cleaning depending on the data you'd
want to do different things to get it in
a in a format that can be easily
consumed by a machine learning algorithm
and we'll look at that when we get to
the demo and then the next thing you
want to do is split your data and the
reason we do this in
even though I think a lot of people in
this room already know is because if I
just used all of my data so if I took
that whole percentage of training data
still to model the Train and then I took
let's say for example if I'm using this
guy and I feed all this data in and then
I ask it okay model what is a house that
is 2,000 square feet in zip code for 807
five how much is that going to cost you
trained it on that data so it that's
something that kind of already knows and
so really the good text of how well your
machine learning algorithm actually does
is how well can it do on data it's never
seen before so typically what's done is
you can split the data and there's lots
of different ways to do that you can
also use cross-validation where let's
say if our K was 10 we could split it
into 10 different chunks and then use
nine of them to train and then test with
the 10th one and then use a different
nine and then apply that 10 so isn't
various ways to do that to support for
that in here as well but I'm kind of
showing the simple example is if your
data set is large enough you can usually
just do a random split and that will
work to find and so we want the training
data to be the majority of our data set
so typically like a 70/30 split is just
fine but there's variations in that you
can do 8020 or 75 25 but let's say we
take 70% of our data and we use that to
train our model and then we have some
algorithm that we use and that defines
what the math is to find the
correlations between that feature and
that label remember okay and then what
we can do then is that will spit out a
trained model for us and then we can
take that 30% of the data we held back
and then feed that in and so what will
happen in this score model is it gives
them just the feature so just those
features into the model the model
produces outputs but then you can
compare them to those known right
answers that you have since you've held
back that data and see how well it does
and then based on that it will score the
model and then you can actually do the
same thing right over here or in this
another model just I be using the
pointer if I'm missing recorded you can
do the same thing over here by may be I
start and I do kind of the same cleaning
and I split my data and in this case
maybe I'm training another model with a
different algorithm so there's a little
bit of art to data science right so I
try maybe a couple different algorithms
maybe I start with a you know linear and
and non linear one
and then I kind of try a couple
different things so you can kind of do
two of these in parallel compare them
against each other see how well they
compare iterate iterate iterate and then
maybe once I'm happy with the algorithm
maybe I want to start tweaking the
initial parameters and seeing okay you
know these parameters that I'm passing
in how well are those performing that
sort of thing you can continue to
iterate on this until you're happy with
your model but this allows you to
compare two side by side to help you
with that iterative process all right
and so then the next question you might
have if if you weren't a machine
learning expert was okay maybe this kind
of makes sense but then this algorithm
that you have here is if every machine
learning has these twenty five different
algorithms how do I know which algorithm
I should use and enter the azure machine
learning choo choo choo choo choo choo
and actually have just a couple of these
up here as well so if you want to grab
one afterwards you're welcome to take
one this is the older version and this
is the newer version that I'm showing
right here but essentially what this is
is a large friendly you know don't panic
button in the middle and then it tells
you what you want to do or you can kind
of look at what you want to do so if you
want to find unusual data points you
would do anomaly detection if you want
to kind of discover structure and
grouping in your data maybe you want to
run clustering on it and then we have
our predicting values and predicting
categories for regression and
classification like I talked about
before
so let's do a quick quiz here if I have
a whole bunch of demographic information
about passengers on the Titanic such as
their age their gender their about how
much they paid for their ticket like
that sort of thing and I want to predict
whether they survived or tragically
perished what would I use clustering
anomaly detection regression or
classification classification ten points
to Gryffindor
all right so I'm predicting categories
on my predicting three or more or to two
right there were no zombies on board the
Titanic everyone one or the other so
there we go so now what it does is it
takes
to kind of this section here where it
kind of in this version of the cheat
sheet it gives you kind of where each
which each algorithm shines so this one
like SVM support vector machines are
really good when you have a large
feature something there's a lot of
different features they do really well
some of these are linear some of these
the decision trees there's a bunch of
them solvable with decision trees here
and those do well but like a booster
decision tree is going to have a larger
memory footprint for example so it kind
of tells you a little bit about where
each one of these might do well and then
you can do that and then the older
version of the cheat sheet which I have
for somebody's and it's on my blog and I
can send you a copy I have a demo that
if you really want to see that one as
well but it's um this one is a little
bit more it's more like flowchart II
which I kind of like a little bit better
because it's this one is more like
declarative in nature and this one's a
little bit more it asks you questions
and then you follow the lines and I kind
of liked that one better but it all
depends on how you how you best learn
but anyway there are these resources
like this to help you if you need it
alright so if you do want to download it
I did stick a link online where you can
grab it and I also have a blog post on
kind of getting started with our machine
learning I did write it specifically for
a student audience for some students
that we're doing a hackathon so on the
first the actual title is on how to win
a hackathon with Azure machine learning
so you can ignore the spin in the first
paragraph if you want and then just the
rest of it is really just how to get
started with Azure ml but it's it's got
some interesting information like where
can you find if you want to just do more
with machine learning or try it out more
where can you get interesting datasets
to play with and where can you and then
there's kind of a walkthrough tutorial
that helps you find end to end there's
information on like retraining
programmatically and some of this other
stuff so there's kind of a whole bunch
of interesting stuff in there so and the
link to the the feature request section
which is actually really really
interesting because you can see their
features where they're like oh this is
in progress and then you can kind of
cheat and see like oh what's coming
there's actually some some nice
giveaways on that side too so good stuff
okay so that's that so let's talk a
little bit about data ingestion there's
actually four different ways to get data
in Azure machine learning and there is a
blog post and a video of how to do it
right
there but let's actually just go through
it so we're going to start the demo now
so I'm going to jump over here and we
are going to go to a new experiment
because I want to do kind of show you
everything from scratch here one thing
that I will say we don't really have
time to do this today but when you get a
chance just look browse through these
samples because they are awesome there's
a lot of neat things here you can see if
you guys are probably familiar with the
various test sets of like on handwritten
digits and being able to map those and
then there's some really good stuff on
there's a nice anomaly detection I've
used a sample a couple times there's
some neat classification problems
there's some like customer like CRM type
data here producing like customer churn
and stuff like that there's a network
intrusion detection sample a flight
delay prediction a sentiment analysis
one that's kind of interesting to see
what people are saying about your brand
on Twitter is kind of neat on some
clustering problems finding similar
companies and clustering colors together
so there's all kinds of neat so that
one's new I remember this one the the
presidential campaign finance data I
haven't seen that ok we're going to rush
over that real fast
um and it's a lot of cool stuff in there
so check that out it you leave for when
you get a chance but this is what it
actually looks like so it's a
browser-based thing you don't have to
download anything to use Azure machine
learning you can just go to studio des
rimmel net and try it out there is a
free trial version available where
basically you can use it if you you can
use it even without a Microsoft account
and if so you'll log in you can use it
for eight hours and I think after eight
hours it shuts off if you do have a
Microsoft account so it's one of those
things we can get a free account you
might have a Google account a Microsoft
account of you know those kinds of
things but if you if you log in with
your Microsoft account then it will
associate that with your with your
Microsoft account and it will actually
be saved and then you can come back and
use the same things over and over again
yes the first plans do they have
anything for academia like researchers
the question is in the price plans do
they have anything for academia the
answer to that is no what I tried so
hard work
really alike so we do have the
DreamSpark offering for students but
however for some silly silly reason I
don't understand why every other offer
that we have around Asher is on like
price space right it's up to X amount of
money per thing DreamSpark is the only
one where it's not it's both price
constrained and feature constrained so
like with the DreamSpark I think it's
like websites and virtual machines a
couple other things that they think that
students would be more interested in but
it's like learning how would I not be
interested in machine learning like ah
so I have been making this point loudly
a ladylike but loudly over and over
again and so far I have not been made
any progress but I look I will keep
trying
yeah but I'm sorry there's not a really
a great answer yet there are a couple
things I think there is something on the
web let me pull it up at the end but I
think there's a blog post on the Azure
machine learning blog that shows a
couple different ways you can do it but
there's also a ways to get like some
free credits and it's not like that -
and you can use the free trial and I
actually think I might even have some as
your passes laying around - so there's
probably ways but it's it's not as easy
as it could be but anyone can do free
like the free there is a free tier and I
think they assume that like students can
just use that if they want to use it
just use a regular free tier so anybody
can use all right any other questions
all right so let's let me start with the
four ways of getting data into Azure
machine learning that I start and then
we'll do the Titanic sauce all right so
the first thing is um saved saved
datasets so if you want to do this one
thing you might want to do is just kick
the tires check it out in which case you
could just use some of the sample data
so the first one is sample data so when
you start and launch as a
machine-learning there's a whole bunch
of interesting datasets in here there's
some automobile prices of the UCI bike
rental data which is a very famous one
that's used over and over again in
machine learning classes and such an RGB
image of Bill Gates in case you wanted
to use like facial detection or anything
like that and it's fun some book reviews
if you wanted to do like a
recommendation engine a bunch of breast
cancer data some great
CRM data the flight delays data this
German credit card data which is nice
for the fraud detection stuff some movie
various movie data the handwritten
digits if you want to map okay this is a
six this is a seven movie more movie
tweets and stuff for your movie
recommendations so those like all kinds
of interesting data in here so you can
check that other some Wikipedia data
scraped up Wikipedia um so there's all
kinds of fun stuff to play with and then
to use it you just drag and drop it onto
here and then you can wire stuff up
alright so way number one is sample data
second thing you could do if you wanted
to upload data is you can do if you have
some data locally that you want to send
up here you would do that as a new data
set so for example I had some data I did
from a project I worked on on the store
it as a CSV locally and so to do that
this one's the trickiest one because
you'd think that it would most of the
stuff is all under here but if when you
want to upload it from the local thing
you actually have to do new and then
data set and then you upload something
from a local file here and so you select
some data on your hard drive and then it
supports various different types of CSCS
TSVs
SVM lights and and a couple of others
those are data as well then one here do
R as - okay nice so we got the cross
thanks awesome so you can upload all of
those as well so that's another way and
then once you upload them it'll show a
little uploading right here and then
once they're uploaded they'll appear
here under my data sets so then you can
drag and drop them into here alright so
that's the second one is that so let's
do let's do the Titanic training site
right there so that's an example of an
uploaded data set then the other two
ways are found right here logically
under data input and output the third
one is entered data manually so with
this one what you can do is specify a
data format and then if you have a
header you could say something like
square feet and the price and then do
some more data that 2,000 square feet is
200 thousand or something like that
now my friends one wouldn't really do
this in real life in machine learning
you need a bunch of data and you're not
going to hand type all your data because
that's crazy talk so there's two
scenarios I can think of where I find
this actually useful
number one is demo so what I'm doing
demos and I want to just throw something
real quick
you can use it for that and the second
thing is like a lookup table so sometime
you might want to do just a quick lookup
table and you might just type that out
by hand so for example if you're like
the flight delays data if you wanted to
do a lookup table that DNA actually
means Nashville and GTW means Detroit
and you know kind of have a lookup table
for like airport codes or something like
that awesome like maybe you would use
this to do that but there's not a ton of
other scenarios yes sir mmm there you go
I like that that's a great scenario I'm
so creating corners of edge cases like
maybe throwing a little sample data of
crazy cases just to feed in there and
see how it does great scenario
awesome awesome okay so that is entering
data manually another thing and there's
a bunch of different formats for that as
well so you can see we have support for
various things here too all right and
then finally the last one is importing
data and import data is used when you
want to basically suck data from
somewhere else on the Internet all right
so if you're doing if you're kind of
uploading it locally use that new data
set if you're pulling it from somewhere
else on the internet you would use this
and so you could pull stuff over HTTP
your museum in a little bit you can pull
stuff over HTTP you can run a hive query
if you're doing any kind of big data
scenario where you're using Hadoop or on
HBase or something like that and you can
execute a hive query against it to get
some data back and then all of the azure
as your sequel database as your tables
natura blob storage are all supported
I'm giving you the generic OData feed
per you can actually access an on-prem
sequel database in a secure fashion and
then as your document DB which they
actually just renamed the cosmos DB
and I guess they didn't update it in
here yet at that time so that's just
like a it's like a it's like MongoDB
it's a non relational database format
okay so then if you don't pick one of
these let's say I wanted to use an O
data provider you can just go there and
then kind of feed in all the other
information that you need and then be
able to grab data from there okay so
that is that so now let's start I'm
going to actually delete all that so
those are the four ways um that you can
grab data into here so I'm going to go
and delete all of this now and we will
start with the Titanic so first of all I
most people nor have heard of gasps of
taggle but the rest of you are in for a
treat cattle is the best so the reason I
love taggle is because if you want to
just like get better at machine learning
and do machine learning there's really
two things you need number one you need
an interesting problem to solve right
and the number two give you data to
solve OS so you have to have both of
those things and what callate gives you
both it gives you exactly what you need
so if you just want to like get better
at machine learning and just play and
learn and maybe even once win some
amazing cash prizes but you can do that
so Cargill is it's taggle can go pee
GG le Kaggle and what it says and
actually Google just bought them and I
was so mad because I wanted to buy them
and it didn't they beat us and I was
like really sad but that's awesome for
Google but so what what they can do is
they're they're hosting a competition
they hope they host data science
competition so it's really really cool
and Microsoft has hosted things on here
on Yelp Facebook Google like a lot of
people have hosted kind of really
interesting things you can see be a
Zillow and Intel right now and some
other cool stuff but basically what they
do is you can click on each one of these
and they give you a really neat kind of
challenge and kind of explain the
problem so in this case this is for
Zillow it looks like they want to see
can you predict the example of our
mouths beginning how can you predict the
value of a home so kind of an
interesting problem there cervical
cancer screening that's awesome look how
cool that to work on a really like
fulfilling challenge like that and be
able to maybe make a difference and so
you can see they actually a lot of these
big corporate sponsored ones have a
large cash prizes there's also kind of
some interesting things using satellite
data to understand the Amazon rainforest
from space and some other things if you
click on any of these you get some neat
information about the project and so
there's a whole bunch of sponsors ones
here at the top and then there's just
kind of some ones for learning as well
so there's like a playground one and
then these are kind of some getting
started ones and so if you look here I'm
actually using the Titanic example data
five and I have already downloaded it
from from taggle but what it gives you
is all of this demographic information
and with the demographic information it
gives you information on you know where
the good thing I've already downloaded
it so we're all set but that's kind of
sex on CagA Oh hmm google by simon look
what happens I'm teasing I actually love
Google so did anyone know Larry Page
when he went to when he went to U of M
okay all right there you go
okay cool I met him at U of M so no I
think a lot of pseudo okay so we're
going to so what we're going to do is
I'll skip over that but essentially what
happens is each one of them have like
three like kind of a series of sections
on the catechol page where they give you
a a kind of a description of the problem
so here's the problem then they explain
the data set so there's all this kind of
neat information about the data and what
kind of cool things that you can do one
kind of like here's what these different
values mean if there's like some letters
or kind of odd numbers in their
description of what the column headers
mean all that kind of thing and then
they give you a place to submit all
right and then you can submit as many
times you want through the conferencing
and what's interesting is they have a
public leaderboard so you can submit you
can see exactly where you're ranking on
there but then what's cool is when they
actually close the contest they use a
different set of data to run the final
competition so the person that's number
one on the leaderboard still may have
overfit their data to that particular
you know set of data that the the test
the leaderboard was on and may not end
up winning on number-one on the the
actual competition so it's just it's a
really fun way to kind of hone your
machine learning skills I am I'm a big
cattle fan as well alright so we're
going to start with the Titanic training
fact I've already downloaded it and I'm
going to utilize it from right here so
what's kind of the next section is let's
just kind of explore this data set and
I'm just going to kind of brain dump all
of the things I think about when I look
at this data set and then we can we'll
go back and implement it after that so
I'm going to just right click on there
and hit visualize and then in the
Mishnah a dremel tool I wonder if there
was a ok good I'm just going to kind of
look top your world of data and so we'll
talk through what we would do with it
first and then I'll go back and
implement all of it so we're going to
kind of do exploratory first alright so
first things first we can see here that
there are 891 rows in this data set and
twelve columns so ok good information
then if I click on any of these columns
so if I click on the first one passenger
ID I get a whole bunch of information
about it just looking at it and so just
by eyeballing the first thing one two
three four five six it looks to me like
that is a randomly assigned integer EDI
in the path of the name being passenger
ID
it looks like a randomly assigned
integer but I can actually confirm that
by seeing that the minimum is 1 the
maximum is 891 and there are 891 unique
values which is the same as the number
of rows on the data set so confirmed
that is a randomly assigned integer so
do we want to use that as a feature in
our machine learning algorithm no that's
essentially noise that has nothing to do
we wouldn't want to do a decision tree
that says if passengers IDs was 7 then
they died because then that doesn't
extrapolate well it's new data right so
you don't that's something we would want
to we would want to drop so what but so
ordinarily I would drop it but the thing
is with Kaggle challenges you actually
the format they want you to submit it in
is actually passenger ID and then the
prediction they want like just those two
things in a big beefy so what I'm
actually going to show you how to do is
how to keep that value with the data but
not use it as feature all right so that
it goes through the
data set and then you can actually have
it with associated with your output and
then but we won't use it as a feature so
I will show you how to do that alright
the next thing is survived so this if
you look at the maccarrol thing what it
says about it is actually whether or not
they survived or tragically perished on
the Titanic and so we can actually look
at a little bit more information here if
you look at the visualization section
you can see in this data set that I have
that approximately 62 percent of the
people tragically perished and then
about 38 percent actually survived and
there's you know all kinds of
interesting data here kind of the
min/max and two unique values so this
looks good we want to keep this data
this is not actually a feature though
right I want this to be my label yes so
I'm going to make I'm going to turn this
from a feature into a label is the one
thing I would like to do this the other
thing I would want to do with this is
right now it is a numeric value however
I don't actually want to do like math
with it right so when you think about a
couple sometimes there are numbers that
you don't want to actually treat as
numbers so thanks for example of the zip
code example that I used in the
regression problem at the beginning when
I was comparing number of engines number
bathrooms and then the zip code right
would you want to average like zip codes
together like it just doesn't make sense
to do math with them right because
they're they're actually just
representations that mean Ann Arbor
Michigan or San Francisco California or
whatever so when you have data like that
you actually don't want to leave it as
numeric but you change that the
categorical so that way it just means
this is a number that is represents this
thing the state so I'm going to make
survived from numeric into a categorical
from a numeric feature into a
categorical label is basically the only
thing I would want to keep this data
that's what I think about this class the
next thing is the passengers class all
right so you can see on that we have
actually three unique values here from
one and three well one is the max ours
right the reason max what is the min so
I'm guessing that the middle one is two
but we can actually confirm that yes
right here by looking at this little
layout right
and you can see they are all one two or
three and so you can actually see the
light the the kind of percentages here
that twenty four percent of this data is
the first-class passengers
twenty one percent of second-class
passengers and then fifty-five percent
were the cool third-class passengers
that were doing like the Irish dancing
in the basement of the or in the lower
decks of the of the ship since the movie
Titanic was completely historically
accurate I'm sure of it
okay so this data do you think that this
is going to be relevant to whether or
not they survived as a class of the
passenger yes I think so too and then
what I want to suggest we're going to
leave this in as a feature
right now it is numeric in this case I
would also make this one categorical
because really what you're talking about
is like a first class and second class
and a third class experience so I
probably change this one to chat Agora
cool as well the next one is a name so
name is a string feature and there are
891 unique values when there are 809 91
unique values and 891 when the number of
rows matches the number of unique values
in any column that's probably not going
to be a very useful column just in
general words you could live by so on
what this means is so these are the
individual names and again you wouldn't
want a decision tree that said if your
name is you know Lena or DiCaprio you're
going to die there's there's somebody
couldn't like scooch over a little bit
on her little door or whatever it was
that she was hanging on but so these
kind of things you'd want to do now the
machine learning purists know that there
may actually be some signal in here
right you could probably find like one
of those things and do some kind of text
analytics on the name so if there was
like a vendor bit or some of these other
names that were historically known to be
like well-to-do names then perhaps those
people would have a more likely chance
of surviving so there may be some signal
in there but I didn't just not worth our
time so I'm just gonna throw that one
out so name I think we're going to just
pitch that
all right the next one is gender and for
gender we can actually look at the
distribution because it was interesting
as well we have 65% male and 35% female
in the state of fact and so do you guys
think the gender is going to be relevant
to whether they survive yes I agree they
did board the women and the children
first
so being female may give you a higher
survival likelihood so we're going to
leave this in as a feature the one thing
I would change here though it is a
string so I don't actually want to do
text analytics on the word female and
the word male right you don't we don't
actually care about that as a strength
so that's another thing that I would
change to categorical so that's the data
that would make sense we have male and
female is two kind of discrete buckets
we don't need that as a string so I'm
going to make that categorical as well
is the line yes great question so being
able to do visualizations in general we
have positive recording I use other
tools than our machine learning to do my
visualization so there's to be fair it's
it's really good at what it does but
that's not one of the things that it's
super good at is doing a whole bunch of
different visualizations like that so I
use other tools outside of this to do
those comparisons and some of that data
exploration stuff and then when I import
things in I can just kind of deal with
this part of it there but it's a great
question that is something that I
usually do it outside of as UML the
visualization yeah any other questions
that's a good question yes sir what do I
use for my data visualization that is a
good question so it varies on sometimes
I use tools like ggplot and stuff it
depends on the format I have it in if
it's in CSV I'll use Excel like I'll
just do it right in Excel and just
because you can do some fancy pants
charting right in Excel or I will use
ggplot if it's if I have the data in
sometimes other formats I use ggplot and
we'll kind of draw things like that so
it really just varies and then if you
use R there's seen of different things
you can do there too so there's a lot of
great things but um yeah there's a lot
of different visualization tools out
there yeah any other questions
all right
all right so we'll jump back to the
Titanic so we're going to leave this at
the feature but we're going to change it
to categorical that's what we've decided
on gender fabulous all right the next
thing is age all this one makes me so
sad you guys because what's the minimum
age was like less than six months old
like that's just heartbreaking and then
we had up to an 80 year old on here so
um age is kind of interesting there's
actually a lot of really neat things you
can do here with with age so you can
leave it as a number and that's what I'm
going to do just in terms of simplicity
so that we're not here like all night
doing kind of everything but there's a
lot of cool things that you can do with
this data so first if you do exactly
what he suggested which is plot some of
these things and how they correlate you
may find that for example there's like
kind of the child experience the adults
experience and the elderly experience
and those may correlate strongly to each
other and to death and that's actually
really interesting because you see that
a lot like in predicting disease a lot
of times there's and this is why this is
why we need algorithms that are
nonlinear as well as not as the disease
thinks because a lot of times the very
very young infants and the very very old
elderly are way more susceptible to
dying from these diseases and so when
you're trying to predict the likelihood
you're going to see something we're like
the probability is high or correlate
strongly for very young and very old and
then the middle it's maybe more likely
to survive but you know you're going to
have a curve that looks like this and no
matter how hard you try unless you get
into higher dimensional polynomials
you're not going able to fit you know
you can't fit a line to this right you
need a quadratic at that point so really
kind of interesting stuff so you can do
so couple different ways you can do this
we could make it categorical and say
kind of 0 1 2 4 I am I'm you know a
child or an adult or elderly or you can
do just leave it as a age you can also
do there's a lot of different things you
could do so data exploration and touches
is one way to do that a little better
all right for this case I'm just going
to leave it as a number in there but you
guys agree age if I'd be relevant yes
because women in children were aborted
so that likely is all right next to our
are interesting as well so this is a
this SID SP stands for sibling or spouse
and this parch stands for parent or
child so they talk about the the family
units that are involved in the folks in
the Titanic so if I look at siblings and
spouses and and who they have who has a
sibling our spouse you can see kind of
some interesting data here this zero
like there's up to some people have
eight siblings or spouses on board and
then that goes you know many people have
none so you could actually do a couple
different things with this so one thing
that would be interesting is to combine
them into like am i part of a family
unit or not so you could turn this into
a binary of part of a family unit or not
part of a family unit and that might be
especially telling for the men because I
know if it was my family on board I have
three little kids and my three-year-old
boy he'd be jumping off the release boat
the first chance he got because he would
think that was hilarious
and then so maybe if you have a large
family like these you know eight kids or
whatever and then you are you know maybe
the man of that family is more likely to
actually make it on board to help Corral
all of these children then then a
bachelor so that merit there may be
something to that as well so you could
use sibling spouse and parent child to
be able to do that and there's just
interesting data to play with here so
again there's different ways that I
probably process this with a little more
time so you could make these into a
family unit binary or a couple different
things you could try to actually match
up the family some people have done that
as well alright so but we're going to
leave those in there as numeric features
for now all right the next thing is
ticket so I would like to meet the
person who designed the titanic's
ticketing system because if you look at
this first ticket it is a letter
backslash a number space and a bunch of
numbers the second line is two letters
no backslash a space and a bunch of
numbers the next one is for letters
backslash letter number period will you
throw that in
and in a bunch of numbers and then we
have some little just numbers with no
letters so whoever does so I am actually
going to throw out this data for two
reasons number one because I don't think
the actual ticket number that's on the
ticket is that relevant and number two
because I don't want to parse that
gobbledygook because I quoted by net
right so that that's ticket so it is a
string I think I think we're probably
okay with not having that as a feature
yes Marcus I'm just training and
curative is really just beating a dead
horse
look can you use the tickets as like a
lookup to figure out where on the boat
they were nearer to the life so we have
cabin number as well so I usually used
to have a number to do that but it's a
great insight so Marcus made the point
that could we use the ticket number to
look up where on the boat they were and
so that's a great insight however I'm
going to use a different column if cabin
number is one of the ones we haven't
looked at yet and so that that's what I
do
and if you guys if you do so what we'll
do that in just a second why are there
fewer good questions so I think my
hypothesis on this so the short answer
is I don't know but I've also noticed
that in my hypothesis is that a family
maybe has one ticket for the whole
family where it's like here's the ticket
and then like there's six people on this
ticket is what I'm guessing but I
honestly do not know the answer to that
does anyone know it's Lucia yes Kevin
you're missing booted oh yeah still
missing values so there's missing values
show up in each one of these as well so
you can actually use do some data
cleaning on that for for missing values
but that's that was my assumption since
all of them have that that just means
that they've been reused a couple times
so since a zero missing values okay
so the next thing is fare so how much
did the ticket actually cost so this one
I think is a little more telling than
the actual ticket because you can use
this to kind of see you know
approximately how much they paid and get
a sense for their um maybe their club on
the boat so there was a minimum value of
zero like some young ruffians that just
gambled their way onto the ship two
minutes before it departed from port and
then we have up to like five hundred and
twelve dollars which was quite
a lot in that time period so you can see
kind of the layout and the majority of
people paid that money paid Wow
so there's a lot of different value to
but you can kind of take that and look
at the histogram to kind of get a sense
for what what that looks like and then
um again there's no missing values here
and and then 248 unique values which
have you nuts it's kind of like when you
get asked to speak at a conference in
Europe and you're like really excited
and so you check the ticket prices and
it's like $1,000 and you're like that's
not that bad
so you go and you talk to your husband
and you figure out a day care and you're
like I think we could maybe make us work
and you talk to your manager and he's ok
with it you're like good I think this
might actually work and then you go back
and you check the and you think you're
okay and then you go back and you look
at the ticket my skin and it's like
$3,000 and you were like romantic
cookies why are you doing this to me so
like yeah it's nice to know that was
still happening in the days of the
Titanic right 248 unique values to
different sticker prices you're the same
right okay yes sir that's a good
question I we could probably figure it
out from the data I have not actually
explored the data said oh that's a good
cry haven't asked that question of the
idiot and it's a good question we could
do some code afterwards and figure it
out but yeah I don't know that's a good
one
maybe I listed that any other questions
I can't answer yes sir family member at
any cabin yes yep that's one way you
could certainly do it so the problem
with cabin let's move on the cabin year
so first of all you guys a great feature
yes for the for the fair how much they
paid is probably relevant all right and
then in America's office food yes so we
also have a record elizacass yeah yeah
yeah we not agree with the person that
class like somebody may have bought the
tickets earlier ah lower price for the
yeah yeah great those conduct really
would like to the band off great
question great question so the question
if I can paraphrase for you is some
there are two very similar data points
that may be kind of correlated and if
you're using both features like how does
that work essentially and the answer is
it depends on the algorithm it actually
depends on the type of math you're doing
for some of the algorithms that doesn't
matter and it will still like it can
work around those and for some of them
it does matter and having to strongly
correlated things can be can be really
bad
so it's unfortunately it's the
architects answer it depends it just
it's dependent on the algorithm but for
this particular for the specific
question that you asked we could we
could choose to throw that out and only
focus on that but that's one of the
great things that you could do when
you're iterating and when you explore
the data is you look at the you can kind
of look at the various things and see
okay if I try just this and exclude this
will I get a better you know accuracy
numbers and such and then if I use both
of them together so that's definitely a
question that we would ask when we're
doing that so you're definitely thinking
the right way I love it yes okay
so we're going to leave this one in as a
numeric feature over there on brevet so
let's move on to cabin in the question
that you were asking sir so yes you can
use the the cabin numbers to find
correlations between families and such
the only problem is for cabin
specifically there are 687 missing
values so there's a lot of family
there's a lot of people on board who
don't actually have a cabin assigned so
all of the people that were doing the
Irish dancing in the basement and of the
ship again on the Titanic there's big
kind of open areas in that some of the
holes and stuff and then there were
people who could afford the night to
happen you have yeah like family member
jannettek yeah probably
yes I I would assume so - it's another
question we could ask the data to
confirm that but I think that sounds
like a very sound hypothesis yeah yeah
absolutely and then the other thing is
then you just it's just there's a lot of
missing data so but when that's
available yes that's a great thing that
we can use to make correlations and to
find similar family members as well so
definitely the only holdback is that
there is a ton of missing data for this
so there's a couple different ways we
get processes for
one I'm actually just going to throw it
out because I don't want to be here all
night but this is the only one that I
really believe that this is totally
relevant and I am going to start out
anyway just for time but let me tell you
what I would do with it when you go back
and do this for realsies
so the cabinet number you can do a
couple different things so number one
you can just turn it into a binary of
zero they weren't in a cabin make it a
categorical variable where either zero
they don't have a cabin or one they do
that's one and then the other thing is
if you get if you want to really have
fun on a Friday night there's actually
maths out there of what the layout of
the Titanic and you can actually look up
for all the different cabins are and you
can see like which ones were around the
edge of the ship and closest to the
lifeboats and which ones were more
towards the center and like down a
certain levels because there is like the
ones that are up around the edge or
closer versus when you go down and more
to the middle it's harder to get to the
lifeboats so you can actually use all of
that data to build like a little
classifier for the ones that do have
cabins you can there's a technique
called in samba Li where you can
actually use kind of multiple
classifiers together to make it even
better one and so what you could do is
just kind of grab the data that does
have this and do some fun stuff with
with that as well so that would be
really really fun but unfortunately be
just an interest of time I'm actually
going to throw it out but in real life
if you submit this to Kaggle don't throw
that out there's actually some some fun
stuff in there all right yes sorry your
question from extra question yeah yeah
great question so there's a couple
different ways you can do it so number
one you can do you can try dropping one
and then the other and see which one is
more irrelevant on the gentleman up
front made a great point that is like
the prices may go up or down based on
how close you are to the Titanic or
maybe what the popular opinion was of
the Titanic is maybe the first wave of
take
went out and everybody was like super
excited about it maybe they were more
expensive there and then maybe something
like oh you know early challenge you
know or something you know something
negative and then maybe the ticket
prices dropped for a while so there may
be something where maybe the class is
more telling than that so again you
could try with one than the other and
then see how well they work the other
thing is that there are some algorithms
that where that matters last like the
way a decision tree works decision trees
are actually like they're using
information game theory to figure out
what's the most relevant and then so
some of that will kind of be accounted
for based on that so you can if they're
not independent it's more okay so
there's some algorithms where it's more
okay if they're not completely
independent like that great question
any other questions that's just so much
fun all right let's go back here all
right so that's what we're going to do
for cousin I'm going to throw it out for
this thing that it's really very useful
all right and then finally the
embarkment point so fun fact I did not
know this but there were actually three
different embarkment points the Titanic
stopped at three different ports before
deposited across the Atlantic I did not
know this prior to keep playing with
this data set but it actually started or
stopped at three or four things the
majority of people got on at Southampton
which is that but there were two other
ports as well so I mean what this tells
us since Southampton is like 72% of the
data that's one of those things where if
you wanted to fill in a missing value or
something you know maybe it's safe in
this case to throw in Southampton for
that one if you wanted to do that and
again is this something that's going to
be relevant or not - um - our algorithm
I don't know well let's try it like we
can start and try it and see if there's
anything in there and then throw it out
if not so we can try it at the feature
string so I again I don't want to do
text analytics on those three letters so
I would change this from a string to a
categorical okay all right so that was
my brain dump of how I would think about
all the state of what I would process
why I would choose to make the decisions
that I did so now let's go and figure
out how to implement all of that in as
your ml so I'm going to turn this back
to normal since I've been grown jumping
in and out not that
let's go to just a nice strong call I've
already messed up okay so let's do so
the first thing I'm going to do is let's
remove some data so under data
transformation manipulation there is
something called select columns in data
set and I should really do this properly
so once you kind of learn the names of
them the search is a lot faster to use
but in the interest of sense you guys
don't know this as well I should do this
a so other data transformation there's a
whole bunch of different types of data
cleaning modules and data transforming
modules filtering manipulation sampling
scaling reducing all those kind of X so
under manipulations there's a whole
bunch of stuff you can do Oh besides
using Python and other modules in here
because you can drag and drop in a
little python script you can drag and
drop in a little R scripts you could
also do sequel transformations if any of
you guys are sequel people I love that
just for group by like provides awesome
like if you want to aggregate the data I
can just do a select on our group Ida
and they're missing yes and then it does
really nice aggregations right and it's
actually really fast too so that's a
really nice thing you can kind of use
some of those three languages in there
so sequel in our and pythons whatever
you're comfortable if you want to write
custom code alright so I'm going to take
this data and you can see this turns
green to tell me yes this is an
acceptable data type to pass in here and
then it tells me that there's a little
bang here because I need to actually
fill in some information and so what I
have this selected this will
contextually pop up whatever selected
here so in this case select columns and
data set it's going to say what columns
do you want to select and so I'm only
going to carry forward certain things so
now we have to remember everything that
I just said and do that over again so
passenger ID we wanted to pass this was
something we were going to keep with the
data but we have to set it to be not a
feature so that's so we're going to keep
that survives we're going to keep
passenger class we're going to keep name
we're going to throw out so let me just
push those over the agenda we're going
to keep age we're going to keep these
two we can keep for now on ticket we're
going to throw out fare we're going to
keep and embarkment point
going to keep and then cabin is actually
really relevant but we're going to throw
it out just for time okay so there we go
so now if I actually run this you'll see
that there would only be nine columns
coming out instead of twelve but I'm
going to wait just a second to run it
after I do a little more size okay the
next thing I want to do is this edit
metadata so I can change various things
about my data so let's make a couple of
changes here so the first thing I want
to do and for each one of these when you
edit the metadata you just tell it what
you can make a bunch of changes right
here like changing the data type so for
example if you have a date time date
times are hard to deal with so if you
change it to an integer then that's nice
because it's easier to do math with and
stuff like that so you can switch
between date times you can make things
categorical you can change the fields
like so and then you can actually rename
columns as well right here so what I'm
going to do first is first let's deal
with the passenger ID you can start with
everything and then just exclude the
things you don't want or you can start
with nothing and just include the things
you do want so I'm going to do passenger
ID first and say the passenger ID for
this one I want to in this be everything
by default is treated as a feature as
you probably saw when I was looking all
those data everything was created as a
feature so what I'm going to do is
select clear feature so that will keep
the passenger ID associated with each
row but it won't be treated as a feature
anymore okay so it won't be used as a
kind of an input to my algorithm all
right you'll just be passed along so I'm
going to do clear feature on that so it
won't be a feature anymore on just
passenger ID then since I want to deal
with some different problems I have to
drag another one and let's pass that in
as well and then what I want to do here
is let's do the survives column the next
one and this one survived we wanted to
make that one was originally a feature
and we want to make it a label so I'm
going to change that one to be a label
like so so survived will become a label
then the other thing I wanted to do was
make a bunch of stuff categorical we
threw out some stuff you can make sense
of categorical so let's launch this
again and once I run it it'll actually
parse it down right now I haven't run it
yet so it doesn't it
showing me everything but once I run it
would see that there's only nine columns
there now okay so categorical we want to
make survived categorical you make the
passenger class categorical you've
thrown this out
gender should be categorical it's a
number that's the number that's a number
that's a number that's the number that's
thrown out and then abarkment
I think embarkment we want to make
categorical as well okay you guys
remembering all this from ten minutes
ago okay so then what we're going to do
is take all of these under categorical
and say make categorical and that will
do all those columns all at once okay
and then I think that's all I need to do
right do we have pretty much everything
let's change this name to UM
where am i PI data PI data a a and then
Titanic and then we'll save this and
then we will actually want it and this
is so now it is running it will take
just a second to do that and while it
does it just to get us in the mood
[Music]
oh goodness
oh boy why are you doing fishin okay
so we're going to start with the
experiment so let's take a look I'm just
going to I'm going to just test right
here and right click and hit visualize
just to see right up and so just take a
quick look so we can see we're down from
12 to nine counts of passenger ID is
just a numeric and it is not a feature
good there should be a categorical label
good this should be category two good
good numeric feature good that's what I
want
siblings spouse good yes the America
that's fine that's fine that's fine and
categorical perfect alright so I think
that's what I want so I think we ready
to split our data now so now I'm going
to go here and data transformation and
there is a sample and split here and I'm
just going to do a split now and when
you do rerun stuff since I haven't
changed any of this it will just do
these all super fast it caches all this
stuff for you so it should be pretty
easy um you could actually split my
regular expressions and do all kinds of
fun splits here if you're I'm going to
just pretend like my data set is large
enough that it doesn't matter and use a
lot of large numbers to take care of
randomization for me but I'm going to
say 70 so this is actually the fraction
of rows in a first output node so if I
say point seven here that means that 70%
of the data will come out of here and
30% will come out of here and then you
can do things like stratified split if I
wanted to make sure that the same number
of like survived and died went on like
this side and the side of the data you
can actually do that as well yes sir yes
I do right I think I did have some
missing values and I skipped over that
so there's a couple different ways you
can deal with missing values in general
and it all depends on the the number
like what your data looks like right so
if you have some things like for example
the the the port one where there were a
couple of missing values for that one
in that case like the majority of the
data came from Southampton so in that
case it may be okay to fill on a default
values at Southampton in other cases
when you have missing values sometimes
you can actually do another machine
learning thing to actually predict based
on these other features what do I think
the value here is and and do it that way
sometimes you can throw the data out so
it really depends on the data you know
what what how you want to handle that
and kind of your confidence levels and
what you're trying to predict so another
kind of it depends question I'm actually
going to keep going for now but I can
show you afterwards there's different
ways to deal with missing data in here
as well I'm just because yeah we're
running out of time
so I'm just going to keep going enough
it's a fabulous question okay so
splitting the data so we're going to
split the data then I'm going to build
two of these in parallel just to kind of
show how it works we're going we're on
to the machine learning fun stuff so I'm
going to choose two models and you guys
already correctly said that
classification was what we wanted to do
to do this and so typically if you don't
know much about the data set you may
want to start with maybe one linear and
like one nonlinear algorithm just if you
haven't done any exploration if you're
just playing otherwise you'd look and
kind of see correlations so I'm going to
grab a two class logistic regression and
a decision jungle a decision jungle is a
in Samba love decision trees kind of
like a decision force only they it
doesn't grow in so they actually fork
them back together at the end in
decision jungle there's a paper
Microsoft Research did on it and then
okay then we want to score our models
from so we want to train our models
first this trainer models first and then
we'll score them so train models so I'm
from a train model I'm going to pass in
an untrained model and so note how one
of them turns green and one of them
turns right on me so it's telling me
basically here's the data type that's
okay to pass in so I'm going to pass in
that to one train model and I'm going to
do a second one in parallel to try both
of them pass that in and then I want to
train with my 70% of the data and 70%
ship and then I'm going to see the one
thing that saying is it's asking for my
label column here so I'm just going to
say survived my label and survived is my
label here as well
parameter of conversion great question
so there's actually a way to do that
there's another module that you can do
to do that so if you want to do hyper
parameter tuning there is a to model
hyper parameters and you can stick that
in there and then that will actually try
a varieties and pass in a range and it
will try everything within the range and
then output the best one for you
so yes we do have that capability on yes
sir
okay so great question so let's say that
I have a whole bunch of data
let me I'm going to try to talk and do
this at the same time which may or may
not work so it let's say you have a
whole bunch of data and for each of
these models there are no so here I'm
sorry click on one of these so for each
one of these models there are a whole
bunch of different things there's these
regularization weights there's memory
size there's what do you want your
optimization tolerance to be so every
single machine learning algorithm has
its own little parameters and stuff that
you tweak all right and so a lot of
times when we're doing it in the real
world we just try a lot of different
things and then we iterate iterate
iterate until it works right so with
this what this does is if you use the
tune model hyper parameters instead of
saying single parameter here you would
say give me a parameter range please and
then you stick a hyper parameter in
there and what it does is you can say
are giving try values from here to here
and then it will try a whole bunch of
them so a whole range for each one of
these values and then you can actually
then it'll pick the best one that gives
you like you can say here's the thing I
want you to optimize for like accuracy
precision recall whatever and then it
will give you the best model from that
so it'll kind of automate some of that
work for you yes sir um we do I mean
there's various things that you can use
in libraries and stuff to help do that
for you so ya know there are ways to do
that yep yeah no problem great question
okay and thank you for giving me honest
forgive me that I don't I forget
sometimes ok so now I'm going to to
score models and so what the Train model
that outputs a trained model so I'm
going to stick this into score and we're
gonna take that thirty percent of the
day that we held back and see how well
it does so pass on my training model
here and again I'm going to take 30
percent of the data that
hasn't seen before and see how well it
does with that and then finally I want
to evaluate those two guys side by side
to see how well they do with each other
so I'm going to stick an evaluate model
here and then pass it logistic
regression and the decision jungle one
by one and then we are going to save
that bad boy and we are going to rerun
it okay say that one more time please
using hold into your friend evolve into
another great question so the question
is if you're training more than two
models can you can you do that well the
answer is actually no like the way
machine so you can but what you evaluate
model only takes two inputs so what you
can do is so there's also a convert to
CSV so you can you can run another one
right here and another one right here
have a bunch of evaluate models and then
join them all together there's a join
module and then like dump them to CSV
and then just take the CSV or something
or you can just right-click on each of
them and evaluate them all separately
but yeah but right now for the way the
evaluate works it only does takes two
inputs yeah great question
yep I'm going to right click on the
output of this visualize module and then
what it does is it draws a curve for me
so let me tell everyone what this means
for those that aren't familiar so what
this is actually plotting is the true
positive rate against the false positive
rate okay and so when you think about it
false positives are bad that's when it
you say something is true and it is not
true and the true positives are good we
want that to happen and so perfection
would be zero false positives right so
you're going rule off the side and then
the true positives would be 100% so one
and then rule across here so this is
perfection so the more the higher you
plug that curve the better your machine
learning algorithm is doing so it's hard
to see on a projector but this diagonal
line right here sorry I'm doing on this
for the recording this diagonal line
right here so this is perfection
boop-boop across like that the tighter
you hug this curve the better your
algorithm is and then this diagonal line
is essentially 50-50 random chance
a monkey flipping a coin right so if
your algorithm is not doing better than
that
maybe try start over so we get some
different features or something like
that okay and then what I can do is I
could actually compare the two them it
actually looks like the red did a little
better it tells you that the first one
is going to be the first one that came
in from the left-hand side is going to
be the blue and then the second one is
going to be the red so it looks like
this if we look at our first one that
didn't do quite as well you can see for
each of these it gives you the numbers
true positives and two negatives are
good false negatives and false positives
are bad and then it gave us an accuracy
number of precision we call f1 which is
a combination of precision and recall
and then the overall area under the
curve which is all of them so what we
can see is that here this one actually
did better
it had an accuracy of about 81% so I'm
going to choose that so just thinking
about that let me train this in so this
one was doing a little better so I'm
actually going to set this up real fast
and basically in like I could have done
that in like 10 minutes if I wasn't
talking through everything but if I in
like 10 minutes I was able to build
something that was able to predict this
survival rate with um you know 80%
accuracy which is kind of cool right so
when you think about the business
problems that you're dealing with for
those of you in industry or some of the
cool problems we're trying to solve in
academia like it's really neat to be
able to have a to logistic and what she
kind of try different things in function
okay so what I did was I just hit I hit
I chose the one that had the higher
accuracy one of them was like high 70s
the other one was 81 so I chose the one
that was 81 which was the decision
jungle and then I there was a really
cool animation that I'm sorry that you
missed but basically it took the arm the
score model train model that kind of
garbage stuff we were training this up
and it just it kept in my data cleaning
and then just pass that to that trained
model that I built and then if I deploy
it like so it actually deploys out
stands up a rest endpoint and then
generates sample code for me in a bunch
of different languages which is awesome
so let me just show you this really
quick if we want to it's creating this
experiment and it's done so if we want
to just see one other things the
documentation for this is fabulous let
me just say right here like it so it
generates a help page for you so if you
are a developer and you just want to
pass this to someone it tells you okay
here's all the request headers you need
to send so first of all it gives you
sample code in a bunch of different
languages if you don't want to use one
of those three languages then here's the
request headers that you send here's
what the requests body should look like
here's what a sample request should look
like with all these values passed in
here's the response codes that it will
return here's a sample response and it
kind of gives you what all of that look
like and the datatypes and then here's
the input parameters and what they look
like and then even extrapolated for my
data here's the allowed value so in case
I forget is it you know female or male
or fnm I can just point some of this so
I repeated this thing so maybe I'm the
machine learning person on my team I
create this then I take this webpage I
put my developers to it I'm like home to
that and then they're like got it and
it's really awesome so that's what and
then here's the sample code so their
sample code in c-sharp Python and R so
it auto generates those for you
your search art person you can just copy
and paste that into a visual studio and
it just brought you to see it run and it
works
same thing with the Python and R so it's
just like here's how it works and the
one final thing I want to show you
really fast actually let's do one quick
task - let's test to see if it works
okay passenger ID the maximum number was
891 so we're going to do a thousand
survived we don't know yet so I'm going
to blank that out let's say a
first-class passenger whose name was
rose and she was female and her age was
how old do you think she was like 21 ish
Amy she's 19 okay sorry 19 and she had
zero siblings and spouses she was intact
that she was engaged but she didn't
technically have a spouse yet and then
parents children she had one she had
them at the mean mom right so the mean
mom they wanted her to marry the rich
guy so one parent and then the ticket I
could basically just bang on the
keyboard because that's what their
ticket for might look like the maximum
fare was 512 dollars so I'd be willing
to paid at least 400 right
you think fodder all right so probably
more than they I'm probably 450 maybe so
who do that in the cabin we do know she
had a cabin because she was modeling
necklaces in her cabin so let's just
choose a list and choose a random one
and then embark
point I don't know but I'm going to pick
Southampton because it was the most
common one so it sends this up and then
what it does by default it's returning
all that data so here's all the data we
set up and then this for the last two
parameters or what actually give us the
thing so we can see that she did survive
and we have a 98% confidence that she
would survive so that's very cool and
then the one other thing I want to tell
you about I'm sorry Sean and one last
thing is just that there's this there's
also all of this wired up as an Excel
workbook so this is awesome if you guys
are working with business analysts or
non coders so what they give you is let
me just open this just to show you I
won't run it but just to show you what
it basically does is it says it wears up
everything using Excel macros to call
your certain service so when you do it
enable at once because they downloaded
from the internet and that's bad and
then if you enable it again because it's
running macros I have to say ok again
and what it does is it gives you all of
those various on your inputs and then
you just basically type in the columns
okay for this passenger ID and then you
just fill in values here and then it
calls and in the real life I would
actually do another select thing and
remove so I'm not passing everything
back but then you could actually get
these predictions back ok so kind of a
cool thing to have that automatically
done in Excel to sense if you have a
business analyst you just hand them that
and then they can use your model without
even needing code they can just do it
all through Excel okay so that's the
deployment thing so that's why there are
people that are taking just like a whole
just a single execute Python sticking it
in Azure machine learning and hitting
deploy and using this just for their
deployment story because it's fabulous
like that ok I think that is everything
I apologize for running over Sean but
that was everything if you guys have any
other questions I'm having to stay a
little bit thank you so much
[Applause]
but I also want to be able to grab pizza
maybe instead of doing questions up here
let's move over there and get some food
and hope everybody enjoys us thank you
you think you might grab a